in the far reaches of Papua New Guinea
the Caron tribesman hunt a delectable
dish it has fur fangs and claws and it's
not something most Westerners with dare
to taste it's a bat
the flying fox back to be precise same
we won't mistreat louse
it's tasty meat flying fox a couple of
times a month we eat it to Westerners
bats are the stuff of nightmares and
horror movies just say bat and many
think of vampires sinking their fangs
into helpless victims even in the real
world
bats are thought of as carriers of
dreaded diseases like rabies but in the
Madonn region of Papua New Guinea the
Caron people have a long tradition of
hunting bats as food the flying fox is
the most common read of that here it's
also the largest bat in the world that
means bigger claws bigger teeth and
bigger wings these fruit eaters can
weigh up to three and a half pounds 50
times as much as the average bat
the flying fox bats aren't easy to catch
but for these car and men it is a
tradition they have been raised from
boyhood to use ingenuity and homemade
weapons to nab them today they'll mount
a sneak attack through the thick
overgrowth and come at the bats from
behind the flying fox bats wait
unsuspectingly with their beady eyes and
large wings the men will have to wade
into the lake but there's one problem
these waters are teeming with deadly
crocodiles
everyone said we went into the trees do
I hit them while they were hanging they
fell down and we caught them they fell
into the water
and we got them and put them in the
canoe back at the village fresh coconuts
are cut up for the main dish
the hunters steered clear of the
crocodiles and brought home plenty of
bats now i'm singeing the hair on the
flying fox path the bat is roasted until
the fur is gone then cut up into pieces
and lightly boiled
much of the meat remains raw this
creature has fangs claws and leathery
wings which would make it highly
unappetizing to most Outsiders but these
men's mouths are watering as an
appetizer the chefs also roast sago
grubs a little green garnish completes
the dish as the ones who brought it back
to the village the hunters will eat
first
they eat the bat bones as well as the
meat and how does raw bat meat taste
it tastes like chicken same kind of
flavor it tastes good other places don't
eat them we don't know about their food
traditions we eat them because our
ancestors did and so will our children
and grandchildren
[Music]